ha ha ha ha ha ha ha we're fun here stay
hello my name is grace Helbig if you did
not know no you know your life is
different now I am I making cat so my
insides look like when I say that I've
been watching out of Cuba days on
YouTube I enjoy them very much so today
I thought I would do one I went on
Twitter and I asked you guys for your
questions with the hashtag why are we
doing this grace so I thank you for
having to type in that really dumb long
hashtag with your questions I appreciate
your effort here's my counter effort
let's a these queues we would be any
vegetable which would you be and why
a potato very versatile there
crowd-pleaser they get along great with
drunk people potato becomes french fries
is there not a children's book yet about
you know ugly duckling to Swan potato to
french fries I want to figure out what I
want to do when I leave school I have no
idea and everyone keeps asking figuring
out what you want to do after school is
very stressful and people asking about
it is even more stressful sometimes so
the next time someone asks you ok what
do you want to do when you leave school
you respond I don't know like figure out
why I hang out with you maybe your
thoughts on my cat
the first photo of this cat I thought
wow your cat looks like it's very
interested in what I have to say and
then the second photo that cat looks
like it hates everything I'm saying so
that cat can now stock up dick I really
want one in your life it's not
work-related well next week I'm going on
a vacation I'm going out of the country
for a week so I will have limited Wi-Fi
access so if you do not see me being um
as active on social media that's why and
it's gonna be really nice and we're
gonna take like a step back from social
media for a second and from work and
just get some clarity on what's next
I'm very excited and not at all stressed
about figuring that out are we going to
Coachella is Donald Trump a kind and
compassionate human being no no like we
were pinion on snow leopards same
opinion I have about snow peas why snow
pea that's for sure
is Snow Leopard are you a quick social
media do you have any recommendations
for who to follow I recently started
following a comedian named Gil Azaria
on snapchat and it's a really good time
that on there why are you so indecisive
about your hair what happened to silver
I win silver and then I washed my hair
and then it kind of washed out a little
bit and then I got some more gray puddin
and then I washed it again so if
anything it's just been like a way of me
really bragging to you guys about how
often I shower recently sorry I'm silver
hair anymore because I just maintain I
can almost decent level of hygiene hope
my first thing you would do if you woke
up in Leonardo DiCaprio's closet first
thing I would do would be high-five
myself because all of my years of
suspicions and paranoia about being
kidnapped have finally come true weird
the Leonardo DiCaprio there just
kidnapped me and put me in his closet
and then I probably look to see if he
got to keep that bear suit for a remnant
I am doing with rude people who crush
your already non-existent
self-confidence I'm starting off on a
light note I would say smile and know
that you don't hate yourself that much
to try and make someone else feel bad
you hate yourself
the healthy amount where you just keep
it in yourself and you don't try to make
others show bad people that make other
people feel bad about themselves really
hate themselves so so much
it's a sad maybe do like this
I'm just scratching an itch I only what
sits next to me in class always smells
like farts and sweats profusely what do
I do help I would say try to look at
that person and find something you
really enjoy about them maybe they're
farting and sweating so profusely
because they're in love with you oh my
god you're gonna have such a sweaty
farty boyfriend quickly lap you'd
recommend for me to download insert your
dish promo here hey don't mind if I do
with consent I think a lot of you know
this already but I'm involved in a pie
dish dy SH and it is a food photo app it
is an app where you can post photos of
food that you get at restaurants or get
as takeout and you can rate it this is
wonderful welcoming fun food photo
community that I really like to be part
of I think you would too we had a
meeting about it actually today and
tomorrow Hanna may Marie and I will be
live-streaming on memories you deserve a
drink YouTube channel to talk about dish
with you guys so check that out if you
are watching this before that and also
download dish if you like getting food
from restaurants and ordering out and
taking photos of it and posting it in a
place that it will be celebrated and not
just gone completely consumed amazing I
also were thinking a lot about kindness
a while ago tell us more oh actually
those I mean it's great I think people
should do it and be it one way that you
could actually show me kindness is by
subscribing to my youtube channel that's
it for this Q&A thank you again for all
of your questions I hope you enjoyed
this video if you did give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to this channel because
I just you know I've said it before I'd
love to pass 3:9 subscribers that would
be wonderful
other than that I don't know oh sorry to
all of you that went to Coachella this
weekend because in my house the roots
are playing hey